es importante establecer algo que este
conflicto viene desde 1991 cuando se
declaró en agosto 30 nuestra
independencia se avengan entonces el 12
de septiembre en ese año
en seguida el pse clero la de la
independencia el del separatismo de
nagorno karabaj por parte de la mayoría
armenia esto ha llegado a alguna
evolución de 1994 el grupo de minsk
conformado por la sc rusia estados
unidos y francia colaboraron en una una
propuesta de paz y una mediación y hoy
en día las condiciones son distintas
desde 1994 vemos que el mundo ha
cambiado desde este momento hay una gran
en potencias regionales que quieren un
mayor protagonismo y es rusia la pulsera
putin y la turquía de erdogán nosotros
pensamos históricamente son dos antiguos
imperios que que quieren tener su
protagonismo y esta es la zona el radio
de acción de ellos en msn está en estos
momentos así es profesor entonces viendo
todo lo que está ocurriendo en este
momento se puede decir que los años de
esfuerzo de la comunidad internacional
para lograr la paz en esta región han
fracasado le pregunto si hay alguna
manera de poder lograr la estabilidad y
la paz en esta región
esteban yo no diría ha fracasado el
problema que estaba en una
transformación de todos los principales
actores en la comunidad internacional
primero que todo hay un gran paréntesis
en el multilateralismo y hoy en día
nosotros vemos que a pesar de los 75
años de naciones unidas hay poco manejo
que pueda hacer naciones unidad desde
ahí tenemos que ver que esa dupla
turquía el rusia que también se presenta
un poco en la región como los analistas
internacionales han dicho que es un tema
de poderío militar de ser una
distracción militar pero igualmente
tiene una cogestión diplomática en los
casos de siria en los casos de línea y
ahora nos encontramos en el conflicto de
nagorno karabaj tenemos también una un
eeuu con una política interna bien
compleja en los temas de reelección del
presidente y tenemos de pronto una
europa debilitada por los temas de
crimea de la acción por sociedad de
crimea y un tema hoy en día
del arroz que nos
vemos que a pesar de los esfuerzos y la
visita que tiene previsto es evidente
macrón en la región está un poco o
impide nosotros podemos pensar que clic
es una ayuda de carácter diplomático se
ve un poco ocupado hoy en día profesor
gracias por estar con nosotros que tenga
usted una muy buena noche